on and also that field in shanksville
pennsylvania
the shared experience of september 11th
2001 unified our country
and americans who supported our soldiers
our civilians and their family members
in fact many of today's soldiers were
inspired to join because of the horrific
events
of 911 and they have served our country
valiantly ever since then
on that tuesday morning at 9 37 american
airlines flight 77 crashed into the
pentagon september 11 2001
killing 125 department of defense
employees service members
civilians and contractors as well as the
59 souls
on the aircraft that day
the headquarters department of the army
g1 which was back then known as the
deputy chief of staff for personnel or
the desper
we lost 29 of our family members that
day including the army g1 lieutenant
general timothy maude his senior
enlisted advisor
sergeant major larry strickland and
master sergeant retired
max belkey
who was already in the history books as
the last soldier to leave the vietnam
the panel members before you experience
this event live
in person every excruciating minute of
every hour of that day and they have
graciously agreed to join us today
and share their stories and not just
what they went through that day but how
they've been able to move forward
in our mission of educating this
generation
so that we may never forget
i'd like to introduce them to you right
now
first up is mr mark lewis he is
currently the senior official performing
the duties of the assistant secretary of
the army for manpower and reserve
affairs
back then he was colonel mark lewis he
was the director of plans and resources
in the army g-1 next to him is mr roy
wallace he is the assistant deputy chief
of staff for g1
back then he was colonel roy wallace he
was the chief of compensation and
entitlements for the army g1 back in the
day
next to him is dr jerry kitzhaber he is
currently the principal deputy to the
assistant secretary of the army for
manpower and reserve affairs in the area
of training readiness and mobilization
back then he was lieutenant colonel
jerry kitzhaber working in the army g3
that's our operations arm of the army
and on the end is colonel retired
marilyn wills
she is an experienced educator she has
taught from elementary school all the
way to university level
currently an assistant director at a
vaccination facility in prince george's
county maryland
back then she was lieutenant colonel
marilyn wills one of our congressional
affairs contact officers our liaison
between the army personnel directorate
and capitol hill
now before we get to the q's and a's and
their opening statements just a couple
of housekeeping rules we're here for an
hour
uh we may not go the entire hour but in
in the interest of giving the folks on
zoom and on the phone an opportunity to
ask questions along with those in the
room just ask that you limit yourself to
one question and one follow-up if
there's time for follow-ups at the end
we'll go there
if not i'll give you the cue that it's
time for the last question
and we'll move on for those on the phone
if you would just please remember to
keep yourselves on mute until it's your
turn to be called upon
right now i'd like to turn it over to
the panel for their opening remarks
starting with mr mark lewis sir oh thank
you good morning and uh thank you to my
colleagues also seated here at at the
table uh it's always good to be with
them uh as it was our colleagues who
were the victims on that
horrific attack uh on 9 11.
uh and the remembrance of
the victims in new york and shanksville
pennsylvania also
i personally want to give a shout out to
the first responders who
quickly came to help us in in that hour
that first hour uh
after the attack
so thank you and uh thank you for
keeping the memory of
of our colleagues particularly here in
the pentagon uh keeping their memory
alive i'm participating today in honor
of our colleagues who perished that day
on 9 11. you can you can never forget
those that serve with you
and then die in such a
unprogrammed on
forecasted manner
vicious way that they did
speaking about those specific people
the 29 that were mentioned before by mr
mendotres here
that were in our severe of influence in
the pentagon
they were military and civilian
employees
of the department of defense and your
government the united states of america
they were serving their country through
service
they were supporting their families in a
most honorable way
and of course they earned their place in
history following that day
we were at a relatively stable period of
minimal deployments at that point in
time
uh in our army history so all those uh
folks that i just mentioned
uh had been on station for quite a while
and all of us
were quite familiar with each other
and so the memories uh
uh are very vivid uh that we have them
it was no quick turnover
going on on the staff at that point in
time it was professional staff and
and uh everybody had been interacting
for some point in time i mean nobody had
the imagination that we could attack
have been attacked like that
that's been said before
uh military targets and civilians the
way we were
but in other times in history the
unexpected also occurred
uh pearl harbor sinking of the main
lebanon barracks cobar towers
uh they they were all outside the united
states but who would suspect that we've
had something like that inside the
united states
and that's the uh one of the teaching
points that i talk to young people about
that you
as history moves forward and the
environment around us changes
uh there's always going to be the
unexpected and we always have to be
ready
i consider the military and civilians
killed there and on 9 11 at the pentagon
and around the rest of the united states
they're at the tip of the iceberg in my
mind of this 20-year
war that we on terror
that
was just completed a little over a week
ago
in the in the minds of many and uh
and i for one uh am glad that it's uh
it's over
and now it's ours to
to remember uh those that gave that
sacrifice
uh we're not naive enough to believe
it's gonna be the last time
and so we just need to to be ready
and the generations that come after us
have gotta got to be ready
when you're a great nation uh there's
just people that
that want what you want or don't like
what you want or what you do
and and there's consequences and
sometimes there are bad consequences
my memories general mod was our senior
person
in g1
he was the quintessential general in my
mind
he was smart
he was focused
he was personable he was caring
and extremely competent
i was due to see him he'd been on leave
uh just before that i'd i had been out
for a week myself
and in the middle of september you start
thinking about year-end resource games
i am the manpower chief uh needed to see
him he had a tight schedule
uh we went down about 9 15 to see him he
was busy and backed up
the secretary
debbie ramscher who was also a victim
in the attack that
told us that she'd call us and try to
fit us in
somewhere around 9 30 4 to 10 whatever
uh and then we got a call that he uh was
still backed up so
we were on our way down
and i was on the way back in the hallway
when the explosion
happened down quarter four
one of the events that
immediately the building jolted
and then quickly
filled with smoke in quarter four along
with the
almost
uh
uh prohibitive uh
uh air to breathe uh was filled with jet
fuel fumes throughout the quarter and
then you would later be able to smell
that jet fuel all over the pentagon
we had just moved into that section that
was section one of the rehab
and we had moved in there a few months
before this
uh one of the new adaptations in that um
new wing was the fire doors came out of
the ceiling they didn't come
left to right like you see most fire
doors now they
came down so
immediately when the building got jolted
and the alarms went off those doors came
down and
you were trapped you had to fire at one
end
and you had a door
a fire door down the other
and you were in this container of
smoke
jet fuel and
people running around who were
disoriented because if you weren't
familiar exactly with the building there
you see the
out in the building you'll see those
reflective tapes down around the borders
of the hallways those weren't there
before that was
an after-action piece that came out
uh after the fire or after uh we thought
about that and the pentagon put these
reflective arrows and stuff in there so
people could be oriented should that
kind of situation happen again
hopefully not
uh
it
people like i said were running around
they were coming down from downstairs
which was also on fire
grabbing people around the neck
people weren't particularly shrieking or
crying that i remember
but they were asking how do we get out
of here and down towards
the end of quarter four where it
connects with the a-ring
is an office and it just happened to be
my office at the time
and um
and uh roy worked in there also
it had a
double door that opened off a quarter
four but it had an exit door that went
out to the a ring
so we wedged the doors open and started
shoving people through those offices
they could get out of quarter four and
out into the a-ring and then of course
away from the fire and out of the
building
uh
and as people evacuated of course our
our
mind turned to
who was in the
fire
on the other side of quarter four
and some here were were working in that
area
i'll let them tell that piece but the
rest of us were trying to
grab people out of there got pretty hot
to get in there
and shuffle them down get them oriented
going down the hallway
and uh and then shuffle them out to the
a-ring and then they they dispersed
following that and we can discuss that
in the uh question and answer
uh then it turned to accountability uh
very quickly
after we
had uh rescued what we could get out of
the uh
burning building
uh and then that went on for
for 24 hours to count for everybody with
that i think i'll stop and get off the
stage and let the colleagues say
thank you mr louis mr wallace okay so as
uh hank said i'm roy wallace i'm the
deputy g1 for the army that means the
number two personnelist
inside the army
uh on that day uh believe it or not i
was working for a
family group life insurance
that's when that
it was 2001 when we started allowing our
service members to for a little
additional money to to insure their
families
and i was 15 minutes out of general mods
office
to go in there and explain to him why
prudential life insurance wanted it to
be opt in
and
opt out instead of opt-in
uh
one i'll give you one vignette that we
so after we got shoot out of i was in
2b4 2c 453
which
about 50 feet from the path of the plane
as it slid through i'm here i believe to
tell the story of the 29 people that
passed that day
in the g1
i myself
after the the oxygen got sucked out of
what we called the cubicle farm
huge the walls were c-ring
and e-ring so massive amount of oxygen
which fires
obviously love
if you go back into that same area today
there's four walls
in there it breaks it up
and gives people a lot more time
after we got everybody out myself and
three others were standing in the fourth
corridor at the at the junction of the
sea ring
uh when
out of that smoke and fire that mark
talked about
uh came lieutenant colonel brian
birdwell and he fell right in front of
us
we had no idea that he was as badly
burned as he was
our uniforms at that particular time
were polyester and if you've ever taken
a match to polyester you know that it
turns into a molten
glob
and he had he was wearing his polyester
uniform
different uh with it matted to him and
the four of us picked him up and we
started for the uh
a-ring
when we got to to that a-ring we ran
into that fire door that mark talked
about talked about we had never seen it
we didn't know how to operate it uh it
wasn't clearly marked if you go see that
fire door today
you will see that it has a nice
fluorescent orange
panel on it that you can hit it it opens
for five minutes and then shuts again
to allow you through but we we hit that
door and didn't know what to do
lieutenant colonel bill mckinnon grabbed
his badge our badges operate the doors
and he swiped through the b ring and out
into the a ring while we were carrying
brian birdwell where we were just
happened to be met by triage nurses from
de lorenzo clinic which is our hospital
off of uh corridor eight and they
started treating him
uh what if it wasn't for that
we would brian would probably not be
alive today so after many surgeries
brian birdwell
is now in texas he lives near san
antonio which is the home of the army's
premier burn unit
and he ministers to
burn victims there
he's also a member of the texas state
legislature so there are a lot of good
things that came out of 9 11 and the
horror that there was there
and i will stop there and turn it over
to jerry
thank you again my name is jerry
kitzelberg i'm the deputy for training
readiness and mobilization in asa mnra
manpower and reserve affairs
um
on that day i was in the
working for the collective training
division in the army at the time was
called desk ops now it's called the g357
arrived at work uh about eight o'clock
that morning like just about every day
after i went to the gym i've been
working on a project for general webster
who was director of training and
i was supposed to bring it down to him
sometime that morning he didn't have a
set time
we were actually on the third floor
fourth corridor and general webster's
office was right next to the g3
the g3s office was
right above the g1 which was hit they
lost two people in that office
uh that morning we learned about the
plane crashes in new york and so i
called my wife to alert her to turn a tv
on and just to see what's going on
and i
was trying to get down to general
webster's office but every time i seem
to get way late for one reason or
another
and then uh as i was just about ready to
leave my phone rang and it was my wife
and she uh
we talked for a second and we were going
to go out for
for dinner that night and we decided to
cancel because september 11th is my
birthday
so we cancelled that um
and then she asked me if if i was okay
there am i safe in the pentagon and of
course i said well sure nothing happens
here
uh unfortunately that wasn't true
um
but we only spoke for a few minutes and
i hung up the phone and just as i turned
around the plane hit
and i was in the b ring and there was a
window right next to my office so
there's a it's called the a e drive that
goes between the b and the c ring for
maintenance and other vehicles
and the plane came through the c-ring
right beneath our office on the opposite
side and so there was rocks and debris
and i thought the windows were going to
come in on top of us fortunately they
did not did not
but in any event had i
not received that call from my wife i
had been on my way down to general
webster's office and the plane struck
the g that side of the building it was
between
where i was and where general webster's
office was
so from there
uh we evacuated uh in a very orderly
fashion nobody panicked i think as mark
mentioned
uh got in the center courtyard and we
there were doing accountability
looking around uh and then i noticed
some
uh
people in air force uniforms were
standing in one spot looking at the
ground
and i went over to see what they were
looking at and there was a piece of the
airplane laying there in the center
courtyard about the size of a turkey
platter and it had this stripes from the
airplane so we knew
at that point that clearly we'd been hit
by an airplane
and i asked one of my colleagues at the
at the time i we stood there and i said
well there was two planes hitting new
york we knew that much i said so where's
the second one he said i don't know and
i said well you think waiting here is a
good idea
and
his eyes got huge and he said let's get
out of here so we went
attempted to go to the eighth corridor
and it was like a stampede of people
coming out of the eighth corridor
and we're just sort of at least i was
expecting something else to happen
and that just didn't seem right to me so
we went back in the center courtyard
and at that point they were bringing
some of the injured people out of the
building they were bleeding and burned
as roy pointed out
and security then ushered us out of the
center courtyard into the south parking
just as we got into south parking
a pa horn on one of the squad cars
announced that there was an unidentified
plane coming in our direction to clear
the parking lot so the whole south
parking lot was full of people and
they're all moving south to get under
that underpass that goes under 3.95
and my boss and i looked down i thought
that did not look like a good place to
be because again we were expecting
something else was going to happen
and so we went to the far end of the
parking lot
and noticed there was a delivery truck
that had
stopped and there was someone standing
out in front of me we assumed that was
the driver and it was
and he looked a little peaked and we
came up and asked him are you okay and
he said well yes i was just here to
deliver my load and i heard a noise and
looked up and i saw the plane coming in
and then he said and the son of a
gunned the engines just before he came
in
and we're just sort of trying to process
that and
the next thing he said took kind of took
us by surprise he said he could see the
people
in the windows of the airplane as it
came in
[Music]
and we just didn't know how to process
that for a second so
after that we went over to the pentagon
city mall and stood there in the parking
lot and someone was able to get most
cell phones in work one guy did have
communication with his wife
he passed the phone around and we gave
his wife our wife's name our home phone
number and our name and then she made
calls
to
the wives of everyone that was there
and
right after that the two f-16s flew over
piloted by mark sasseville and heather
penny
and at that point i kind of sort of felt
okay i don't think i have to worry about
any more airplanes falling out of the
sky
not knowing
in any event i meant made it over to a
friend's house he fed me supper that
night he lived on columbia pike which is
right nearby
and about 5 30 he gave me a ride home
and my wife wasn't too worried until i
showed her exactly where i was and what
happened in the pentagon and then she
got a little bit worried
uh her mother
my wife is japanese and her and grew up
in japan and her mother was in tokyo
during world war ii
and was 15 at the end of world war ii so
she was visibly shaken very upset and
worried she had seen war before and and
this was a little too close to comfort
for her
so i can see how she was worried based
upon her background so
with that i'll turn it over to
carter
well thank you and good morning
um thanks for the army
the army always has a special way of
pulling september 11th together
and so thank you for inviting me on this
panel
you know prayers and thoughts go out to
all of those who were affected by
september 11th
in new york
in pennsylvania and of course here in
the pentagon
so who am i i am retired from the army
after 30 years
um i will say every day i loved it
some people will say i was crazy but i
loved it military police officer
and if you know the army we change jobs
over time
so my last job
when i was in the pentagon was the
congressional affairs officer
and i was the congressional affairs
officer for the g1 which was general mod
and mark lewis and el wallis sitting
here on the table
for me september 11th started as a
beautiful sunday sunday morning sunny
morning
my family and i would always get up and
pray together i have two girls and my
husband
but that morning i didn't
because i know i had a meeting in the
pentagon and i only lived 16 miles from
here but it could take you two and a
half hours because of the traffic now
again this is pretty coveted
i smacked my girls kissed him and i got
on the road heading this way
singing my song having a great time for
an hour and a half in the traffic as i
arrived to the building i knew we were
in this great new area you've already
heard that
it was
part of wedge one reconstruction and we
it was just great to be in this new part
of the pentagon
at nine o'clock we had a meeting we know
in the army if you're at nine you're
late so i got there at least 15 minutes
early it's always cold in the building
to me so i went back to my office on the
sea ring
uh second floor and grab my army sweater
i went on to the conference room where
there were about 16 of us in this
conference room for the g1
my chief of staff colonel mcnair
led that meeting
we knew nothing of new york because our
meeting started at nine
probably at nine
as we went around the table i just
glanced at my watch and said oh my gosh
it's 9 20
meeting's going a little long because i
had not spoken yet about five after nine
it would be time for me to speak and
give out information to the staff
as soon as my turn
to speak it was the loudest explosion
i had ever heard
the room went completely dark
i was on the right side of the table
i was blown to the left side of the
table which would be closer to the inner
earring
i knew there was a door in that room not
the door that i entered but i knew there
was a door on the e hall way
so i crawled to that door
and i grabbed the handle but pulled my
hand back because that door was so hot
then i crawled back across the room to
go out of the door that i had entered
not knowing that there were people
behind me
as i crawled someone grabbed a hold of
my belt and i asked who is this talk to
me who is this and she said her name
her name was lois stevens and i told
lois hold on to me i have you don't let
me go where i go you go hold on to me
so i knew it wasn't about marilyn
i continued to crawl and we crawled out
of the conference room to the left
now we know had we crawled to the right
i wouldn't be sitting here
because that's the image you see
when you see the pentagon and it's
completely destroyed
we crawl to the left
through this dilbert form that you've
heard mentioned on the table
i crawled under cubicles we could not
see anything i could not see my hand if
i put it on my nose and i know it's
there
and i continue to talk to lords to
encourage her to say you're gonna be
okay we're gonna get out of here
lois tugged at me and she said she
couldn't go any further
she had nylons on
and her stockings were melting to her
legs
she said colonel i can't go any further
i said oh yes you can just get on my
back i'll carry you i'll carry you lois
when we stopped there were three other
people behind lois
regina grant was on this crawl with me
we continued to crawl on
lord stopped me again
and said colonel i can't breathe
i had my black army sweater
thank god i went back to get it
and i started sucking on my sweater and
i passed
to louis to say here suck on the sweater
and she sucked on the sweater
and it called for regina she wasn't
there
[Music]
that was devastating
we continued to crawl
i can't tell you how long
but i knew there was a window
on that sea ring
so i continued to crawl to that sea ring
window
we got to the window as we all know the
windows are bomb blast proof
but there was a soldier standing to my
right
because the window we could see a bit
out of it it was cloudy but i could see
this soldier to my right we knew there
was a printer there
so we said grab the printer and throw it
in the window
it wouldn't break
the printer fell into my lap on my
thighs
i continued to say we're gonna make it
try it again
colonel mcnair said well let's kick the
frame
so the soldier myself colonel mcnair
starting to pound on the frame of this
window
it popped small enough for a child to
get through it
we continued to pound on it and the
frame popped open the smoke just
bellowed
out of the window
specialist petrovic was burned pretty
bad
so we lured him out of the window
there was a navy captain standing at the
bottom
craig powell
he said jump i'll catch you
so he caught petrovic
we lured lord stevens out of the window
he caught lois
we lowered miss day
out of the window
she looked me dead in the eyes and said
colonel i i can't let go
so i peeled her fingers from my hand
as she fell
she was well in her arms and legs and
unfortunately she injured
captain powell
craig powell
so in her fall he failed as well
so colonel mcnair and i sit in the
window
and i told him sir if if we're quiet
maybe we'll hear someone
so we sat in the window
we heard no one
i knew regina was in that room
so i told him sir let's try to go back
let's go back
colonel mcnair said i'll go back
so he turned to go back and as i look
for him i continue to say sir can you
hear me can you hear me talk to me
he couldn't have been
10 10 feet from me he turned and came
back he said marilyn we can't do it
i said we yell and scream maybe they'll
hear a voice and they'll come to us
we yelled and screamed no one came
colonel mcnair at that point said
colonel
you will get out of this window right
now
the only decision in the army i did not
want to obey
the only order
i did not want to obey because i knew
regina was in that building i knew
marion server was in that building
so as the colonel and i sat on that
windowsill
people in that corridor they started to
make a human ladder of themselves
so as i came out of the window
i stepped on arms and legs and heads and
and i fell
and craig powell caught me
and they contin they tried to take me
off i said no i want to see colonel
mcnair come down to know that he is safe
so i was able to see colonel mcnair come
out of that room that window
and i was taken to triage and center
court
but we lost so many that day my friends
the young man who sat in my chair
marion server
you know she had a daughter
who was getting ready to go to college
and the relationship she had with her
daughter is the relationship i wanted to
have with my girls
so i think of her often and i think of
her daughter
think of all of those who we lost
injuries and medals and all of those
things
the injuries happen the medals are not
something that you want to be recognized
for
but a terrible day but great things
happen after that
thank you miss wills
with that we'll go ahead and open it up
to questions and we'll start here in the
room mike glenn europe yeah thanks a lot
i was wondering if somebody could talk
about uh
the
seeing the end of
of this 20-year
experience
uh i mean you know being at the
beginning of it and now no you know
seeing the end of it what does that
mean to uh to any of you is it i mean uh
you know i was in combat too and i know
what combat lasts you know this has gone
on for 20 years now you know starting
from this experience here in new york
and in shanksville what does it mean to
see this finally come to a come to a
conclusion
whether or not it's the best conclusion
you know we wanted
and for whoever wants to
wants to take that
well
like i said in opening i'll take it for
a second here like i said the open marks
uh
i think all of us should be glad that
combat is ceased
um
and it was a 20-year effort with
000 some soldiers rotating in and out
to afghanistan in particular but
remember at
points in time there we had pretty
intense combat going on in iraq
at that point in time
or during those times
but i think that's over
all the service men and women did their
their job well uh just speaking for for
the army but
those for the other services also
uh well-trained soldiers with uh
well-trained leaders will
always accomplish the mission they
accomplished each of their missions
at the time
in each battle as you know
um
and so and that were those were all
waypoints leading up to the 20 years
and now
a political decision was made to to end
that conflict and and
and that's how we run our government and
that's the best way to do it
all right
mrs watson cbs so i wonder
if each of you could tell me when you
learned it was a terrorist attack and
what that
and what that feeling brought i guess
i guess i can start
so
i wasn't watching the tv i had a tv in
my office and there were three people in
my office watching the tv
with the world trade center
and after all the things
i
finally hit me
when the
pentagon
police force forced us out of the
building they forced me out on through
the e-ring
onto
where the plane had struck the building
and you could see
the debris
because the plane
uh terrible pilot by the way
the plane clipped a bunch of the big
light poles there by
interstate 29
and there was actual debris on the
on the outside of the building there
where the strike was
and at that point you it was pretty
obvious what what really had happened
but before that while we were doing
escape invasion
at 24 years of service which i thought i
would never do
uh ever again
and that was when i realized that that's
what it was
well i realized it
eight days later
because i was hospitalized
and my question to my husband was what
happened
he didn't tell me
he said something happened in the
pentagon my first thought
was we had just moved into this new area
and there was a construction incident
or accident
so when i returned to the pentagon the
g1 had a large meeting over at the
hoffman building
the old hoffman building and that's when
i was told
that there was a terrorist attack
i was angry
i think i heard someone say i
had those people been in front of me
it wouldn't have been very nice
um
i just wanted to hurt someone who would
do this to us
that was my feeling and i think like
most americans we wanted revenge how do
would you come to our country
and do this to the seat
the pentagon
uh
when i was sitting in my chair and i
spun around and the plane hit the
building and there was all the chaos
going on i remember looking across to
one of my colleagues and he looked at me
and he only said one thing
bin laden
and it was just that quick that they put
two and two together and that was it now
we didn't have anything to confirm it
but that was the first reaction
you know i remember obviously i'm
older than my old enough to remember i
remember it was this was at a time when
the gulf war had been over
uh soviet union collapsed
uh we were
um
friends with everybody seemingly it was
quite you know it was it was a beautiful
day both in new york and dc everyone
what was it what was it like
uh and for y'all
just prior to uh you know
the day i mean did y'all think that you
know for some of you who are you know
senior field grade officers or you're
looking at
okay i'm gonna you know i'm gonna
looking i'm at the sort of the downward
slot you know edge of my career in the
military and i'm looking at my life
afterwards and i hope to go fishing at
some point or whatever what was it like
you know what what was your sort of
mindset
immediately prior to
uh new york you know plenty of new york
and then obviously the plane didn't hear
when i came in the office that day was
early like i said i'd been out for a few
days and i was in my 31st year of
commission service then
um
sergeant major strickland who who died
in that attack was in my office
and he was getting ready to retire yeah
yeah
yeah and uh sergeant major strickland
was there um
he wanted wanted to know uh what i
thought he should do
when he retires
uh his wife was command sergeant major
strickland of fort belvoir at that time
um and so we talked for a while and
that's
about about that what i was going to do
after i retired
um and that had a big effect
for what came later on that night i
didn't get to unpack my
briefcase because he was in my office
and i left it on the desk there
and um
and so uh after we had got done talking
i walked with him as a matter of fact
back down to joe maud's office and
that's when i found out that his
schedule was packed
uh sergeant major stayed there of course
i like i said i've turned around headed
back down quarter four
but that briefcase
uh you know the office was filled with
smoke everything back there got all
singed and full of stuff but on my way
out finally when we cleared
quarter four
i grabbed that briefcase that was
sitting there
as i passed through the office because
that was the only way out because that
fire door was shut
inside that briefcase was the social
roster for
this per that i always took when i was
home uh because you know i get calls in
the middle of the night for the set
nothing
and so i grabbed that and then outside
the building there where roy was saying
through the hole in the side of the
building
um
people run over try to
litter people into ambulances and stuff
i had that briefcase i set it there we
lifted litters for a while
and then i grabbed people running up the
highways in every one direction i
happened to find two or three people at
work for me there in the operations
section grabbed them not so fast fellas
and we moved to the engineer trailers
out in north parking the engineers had
their headquarters out there as they
were the renovation renovating the
building here
and i had that roster and we started
going down that thing we knew maryland
had been
taken to the hospital
uh a couple others uh and we knew
approximately where people were and what
they were doing uh during that day so
by two o'clock in the morning i would
call the vice chief of staff and um
we had it down within two or three
people that uh accounted for
uh could never done it without that
roster on in in a briefcase there but
you know outside there i would say
people were running up and down the
freeways just trying to get away and the
thing that jerry brought up you know
there's another airplane coming in that
rumor circulated a couple times that i
remember and people you know get out of
here and other airplanes come in but in
the middle of that an f-16 the u.s air
force f-16 made a pass reasonably low
not real low but over the pentagon so we
said hey
it's over we've got the skies now yeah
um and so people really got about the
business of it back and evacuating
people it's a daily reminder
where roy's office and my office is
right in there that's where the plane
came through we sit there every day
that's where that airplane came through
to answer your question
like any corporation is normal day
business yeah doing normal business
and then when the flame struck i know
for senior folks like myself
24 years of military training kicked in
get your people get them out
make sure everybody's safe
go back in
like maryland screaming into the
fire and the in the smoke this way is
the way out
i didn't lose anybody from my section
but the the 29 friends and comrades and
and mentors
uh were not in my section
that day but it was normal business you
know pentagon is a huge 20 000 people
come to work here every day
massive amount of policy and resourcing
because this is not a combat
headquarters this is a resourcing
headquarters
so corporate think corporate that's what
it was like before that
miss wilson yeah sure for me um as as mr
wallace said
normal day come to work have a staff
meeting after the staff meeting you go
straight to work
doing the business of the day
i had no thoughts of retirement just yet
because i was a junior lieutenant
colonel
so i continued to want to serve
my husband had already retired so he was
there to take care of the girls and just
a beautiful normal day coming to work at
the pentagon
dr kitzhaber any thoughts yeah like i
said it was a beautiful day came in and
went for a run
down the washington mall and you know
being a
growing up on a dairy farm in wisconsin
i never envisioned myself being in
washington dc let alone working here or
in the pentagon so i was just sort of
enamored by the sights and the sounds of
washington d.c that morning got to my
office another day
as roy said you know it's a corporate
headquarters we were working policy i
was working with general webster on some
policy issues
everything was normal
up until about nine o'clock
all right well let's go to the phones
now we have several outlets waiting to
ask their question we'll go to nbc
universal and amanda macias are you on
the line with us
hi there can you hear me yes we can hear
you fine what's your question
thank you so much uh for telling your
stories i wanted to ask um if you could
talk about what it was like returning to
the building post the attack and also
have any of you had any family members
to serve in the wars uh post 9 11.
thanks so much
well i'll start
so uh i'll take your last question first
um
i'm an army brat
and i don't know if you all know what
that is but that's that's a dependent of
a service member my dad spent 30 years
in the army
um army brats go one of two ways there
is no middle ground
they either want to serve or they don't
none of my three decided to serve
so
um
let's see first part was
your return could you ask your first oh
the return
so
my office was in the c-ring
uh after they finished
cleaning up the b ring i got moved back
into the b ring
for those of you that know washington dc
from my office window
i could see the lee custis mansion
on the top of arlington national
cemetery
from the b ring
which is two thirds of the way through
the building
because they had torn the building all
the way down to
its foundation
that part of the wedge
and they built it back over the next
year
a really amazing thing i got to watch
them rebuild it through my window
as those you that know the arm the
pentagon is a national historical
building
everything must be
the same as it was
when it was built back in 1940s
the exterior is limestone
it was quarried in indiana
the stone that sits on the outside of
the new building there is quarried from
the same quarry
from 1940s
they cut the stone the new stone
it was smooth as a baby's behind if
you've ever touched the outside of this
building you know it's rough as a corn
cob
so they actually went back into their uh
facilities and they found some saw
blades from the 1940s 1950s and they put
them on their machines and they cut the
exterior of this building
that you see today and it's real hard to
see where the new starts and the old
ends
the gutters are copper
they had to find coppersmiths to do that
the roof is slate
they had to find someone that knew how
to lay a massive slate roof
but they built it back in and then a
year later we had
a celebration
out there on that side of the building
with the jumbotrons and everything else
there you may have seen pictures
of that but coming back in
for me wasn't hard
but i can tell you for some of the
people our security uh
john yates our security manager
didn't come back for years i had two
ladies that worked for me
that could not enter the building again
uh they couldn't cope
with what had happened that day
so it was different for everybody
based on
your background and your experiences
whereas for me um
haven't been hospitalized for a while
the army gave me several days off and i
came back to work
but i could only come back for half days
when i initially came back
when i came back the worst thing of all
was the smell yep
um you could smell the fumes you could
smell burning bodies you could smell
the burning wires you could smell all of
it
that was the worst for me
you would walk for me i'd walk down the
hallways and i would think that i saw a
ghost because i knew i saw marion i knew
i saw general mod i knew i saw these
people
so the psychological part of it was very
difficult
but i knew i had to come back
because had i not come back my life
wouldn't be as it is today
um
it was difficult when i would go sit in
the new general's office and they had
opened up the flight plan to fly back
over the pentagon again as i'm sitting
in a meeting i'm watching these planes
go by
just put that in your perspective
i couldn't sit there
so the general understood
general lamont understood but eventually
i got there because i knew i had to
continue to serve
did anyone in my family serve after that
i'm like mr wallace no my daughter said
absolutely not
but i did have relatives and cousins who
did go in and serve after 9 11.
dr kitzhaber
we returned to the building a few days
afterwards just to retrieve our
our belongings
one of the things that was still on my
desk was the letter signed by general
kensinger wishing me a happy birthday
covered with soot
and so i kept that till today
um we retrieved everything we could they
gave us five minutes to grab everything
you can and leave and
so we did and we were putting in a an
office out in chantilly we worked there
until about christmas time and then they
brought us back in the building and
again we were in the b ring right above
roy where he could look out
and
see all the way up to the hill to
arlington so
that was my recollection of coming back
to the building i didn't have a problem
coming back into the building
but you can't not think about it when
you do come in the building it's it's
with you
and it's always with you
and it never leaves
other family members i have a younger
brother that's deployed twice
my cousin's son joined and deployed and
fortunately was a casualty to ptsd and
tbi after the fact
mr lewis sir
yeah
we could only come back for the next
couple days in that or
those days
in uh section one there uh wedge one
because it was a crime scene and you had
to be escorted in and out
by the fbi or some representative there
so as we tried to get in get some of our
uh
files and stuff because one of the
remarkable things that happened right
after that we transitioned to war
immediately
and um uh if for the g1 or for the death
per then we
relocated eventually down to the
uh personnel center which was is down in
alexander or was in alexandria
and worked out of there for a while and
then we reoccupied different parts of
the building
a few months later
but the army didn't skip a beat there uh
nor did any other part of dod it
immediately transitioned to war and so
we got very busy doing that
right after that of course
our commencement with that we had the
anthrax scare going on here in town too
and that added
quite a hype to
do lots of things
i i was i was not a personalist like a
lot of folks
i was a combat infantryman serving in g1
and so i'd run into these things a
couple of times both my parents were
commissioned officers during world war
ii
my mother was a regular army nurse and
my dad was a
army air force both saw combat so
uh you know i had my whole life uh with
it and i
i would say i knew what to
expect in that situation because like i
said it would you know who would think
he'd get attacked in the united states
of america
uh it wasn't uh
working overseas or something
but coming back into the building was uh
chaotic for us because we were spread
out all over initially
and then the president united states
said we're going to rebuild quarter
wedge one within a year rebuild it
and as soon as that was built they
relocated us right back into where we
were it's a little bit different
configuration but same
same people the manpower reserve affairs
assistant secretary and
army g1
people moved back in there
yeah they did have some of us come in
before we reoccupied
some of us had to come in they picked
some of us to go in so they put us in
the white
suits with the respirators and all of
that stuff when we went in basically to
get out classified containers
and things like that
i have a shadow box down here that's
made from things from my office
the clock that's in there
probably wasn't supposed to take it out
but
i put it underneath my arm and took it
out with me
it stopped 19 minutes
after the plane struck the building it's
that's how long it took the heat
of the flame to melt the crystal
forever freezing the hands in time yeah
let's go back to the telephone now haley
briskey task and purpose what's your
question today
hi thank you and thank you all so much
for doing this and for being here um
you've spoken a bit around this and i
hope it's not too repetitive but i'm i'm
wondering if you could um speak about
you know the moment or the day maybe
when you realized um
or if you did realize that this was
going to be
um you know as as
the gravity of the situation i suppose
um and you know this has gone on for 20
years after what happened that day i
mean was there a moment when you
realized that this was going to be um
you know as big of an undertaking as it
ended up being um or
was was that not something that you
thought about um thinking more in the
immediate term i'm wondering i guess an
open question for whoever wanted to take
that okay well let me start
um
i think the time that i
that it finally
that i graphed that this was going to be
something that was
going to take a while
um was when i finally realized that this
was a different kind of war
uh before all of our wars were fought
against nation states
and uh
you know and and groups of nation states
uh
and you had an enemy that was
readily definable
the enemy that we've been fighting for
the last 20 years
disappears in a puff of smoke
it's an ideal
it's not a country
and it's a clash of ideals
between the american beliefs
and their beliefs
so and when you're looking at and trying
to fight something you can nail germany
down and you can defeat germany
and that was at the point that i knew
that this was going to be take us a
while because the enemy just completely
abs you know goes into the woodwork and
comes out again
at another place
mr lewis sir
yeah uh
our senior leaders came to that
conclusion
uh fairly quickly
we had obviously
the 29
in our section that had died but in the
pentagon there was uh
70 a hundred and eight hundred four well
with the
airplane airplane airplane people
uh but for those of us in our in our
sections
we the chief of staff at that time
general shinseki
and the secretary put out that there'd
be a general officer and
senior civilian at every one of the
funerals but
when just the funerals it was the
memorial services there were wakes
then there were
church services and then
subsequent uh in-ground burials
and we so that that took most of the
fall
to go through all that we all
participated in and one of the funerals
that i was at the chief of staff was at
and we were talking for a couple seconds
either before or after the
ceremony
and he said you know it's going to go on
for a long time
and i didn't realize 20 years at that
point in time but a long time he said
this could be the long war
to get at this that that sticks with me
okay
let's go back to the phones and rose
thayer from stars and stripes are you on
the line
i am yes thank you so much for um being
willing to share these stories i know
it's really difficult
um i guess my question is a little bit
forward-looking um i know we're on the
20th anniversary of 9 11 and
every year there's there's more and more
adults in america that don't have the
the feeling or remembering of what it
was like on that day to be in america
so what
what is
the message going forward and what is
sort of the importance of
remembering what happened that day
um
for americans like what's what's
what's the value and continuing to share
these stories
okay you want to start i'll start i'll
start okay so um the
i go and speak
to classes two years ago i spoke to what
they call the firsties which are the
seniors at west point
uh and the very first question i asked
them was how many of you were alive
on september the 11th
and only five hands went up
they were prior service
and then i said how many of you were
still in diapers and uh you know it put
your hands down and all the hands went
down
i've spoken to other high schools in the
area
uh about 9 11 and i think that
um
kind of maybe a contrite thing but
freedom isn't free is the message
and if you get recalcitrant
um there's somebody out there that wants
to bloody your nose
uh if you look at places like pearl
harbor i mean mark mentioned several of
them
um
if you don't if you aren't a student of
history there's a wise man that said
you're doomed to repeat it
so keeping at least the message
but i think the real message is the
resilience that came out of it not the
actual act itself
the acts the three acts
itself it's the resilience of the
american public
every single
uh overpass
in this city had an american flag
hanging from it
for months
after 9 11.
and that was the way all across the
nation i went to talk to in the hometown
in texas
to the high school there
american flags everywhere
it was a galvanizing event
that happened
and a lot of good
things came out of it in the end
i think that's the message
the resiliency of the american people
themselves
and the uh
and the that we shouldn't forget these
type of things
dr kitzhaber you had a thought i i guess
i'd echo what he said you know we don't
study history we're destined to repeat
it and
i think it's just important that we're
assembled here today to
remember those who didn't survive
because we owe it to them
to educate
the rest of america as to
what can happen when you become
complacent
and like troy said freedom isn't free we
have to
guard it every day
and watch for areas that we're missing
well said wtop are you on the line with
a question
i'll take that as a no
all right we have just a couple of
minutes for one final question anyone in
the room or on the phone it's yours
all right thank you all very much i want
to thank our panelists today for sharing
their stories with us impactful
meaningful
and again the goal today really just to
continue the education of the american
public
of the importance of service sacrifice
freedom isn't free and that's what we
all stand here for anyone who's raised
their right hand and uttered that oath
that is what we stand for and what the
american public we hope understands
about us and the importance of it as we
observe the 20th anniversary of 9 11
here at the pentagon thank you all so
much for tuning in thank you all so much
for attending
[Music]
[Applause]
soviet style situation
by having child care
and
the president vetoed the bill 50 years
ago
1971.
so it's long long long overdue
that we recognize
the importance of our children and their
care the value of women in the workplace
and the only way that we can truly build
back better is with
women in the workplace so that's why
this is on my theme all along with our
members has been built back better with
women remarkable remarkable uh
transformational initiatives in this
legislation all of them
long overdue
many of them
standard fair and
other developed countries sorely lacking
in our country and so it would be
again again to thank the president for
his vision
isn't as important as infrastructure is
and we support that
it is not the totality of his vision
it's a vision that does not just restore
it to where we were before but takes us
into the future it will take cat it will
cut taxes again uh deliver one of the
largest tax cuts for families ever
with the dividend tax credit i call it
the buying tax child tax
cut
it will lower cost
especially for essentials and of course
for
prescription drugs which is a very
uh it's a health issue and an economic
and financial issue for families
lowering the cost for health